はいというわけでみなさん2010発明最後の動画になります肇社長を応援して
くださった皆様本当にありがとうございました
まあ振り返ってみると多分録画 youtube やってきた中で史上最強にいろんな
ことがあった1年だったのではないかなと思います
まぁちょっと色んな事件を起こしてしまったり動画王すごい休んだ
いい夏休みも忙しくて動画休んだり結構こう上手くいかなかったぜうまくいかなかった
んですけどなんかいいか誰かいるといろんなことを考えるいい1年になったのかなと僕
は思っておりますまあすごいなんか反省すべき点はちゃんと反省していろんなこととし
ていろんなことをまた学べたんで
なんか今こうやってちゃんと道が続けられているのは本当にあっ
支えてくださっているよ事務所の皆様 web の皆様として僕の脳裏の友達そして
何より
いろんなことがあった中でそれでもついて来てくださっている音してくれてる動画を見
てくださってる皆様のおかげだと思います本当に2017年ありがとうございますって
重い話をしててもアレなんで
レズ見せずられるダイエット
rar
me
are you do
[音楽]
eroanime
r 002はっはっは tee
me
持った
セクシーな感じですじゃーん
macha san
pa ああああ
goo bejean
wh
woman 2124って言ってえっ来ず
よと言い方が私の家中身です
ああああああ
[音楽]
car
rar
ある意味の稼いで生活するようになったんは
あー yeah
チャンピオンであるべきいやー匂いが変わるだけだ誰でも持っん
うううう
w boa tarde
アップ芸タイプ hi ああ
5分
わーどんなに頑張ったのです
さあハーツ45が僕ついてたぶー
チーズ kq 角部約4坪で叫びちょっとウェイ
というわけで技セのつけた雪だるま
car
[音楽]
rar
バーコードねこう分かりませんね
[音楽]
それでは今日性と自己紹介をよろしくお願いします
amaran
水を奪われん
イェイ rar
ホラーあああああああ
car
ああああああ
4まずええええ
あっはいどうぞ孤独とパクってるんですよ
な鍵
ブーバー杏実社長だ写真撮んじゃたシーンでいいだろ
[音楽]
逗子署ああああうわぁ
第二号オレはー今ずねーわっはっはー
me
さーああああ
書きましたーーー
このだ ni
ああああああ
俺の全財産ねんね基礎がバカって濃いなあ
ん
音やわけですうわぁ
ブースいい
本人が喜んでくれる良いコーヒー200はっはっは
ん
寂しいな僕こうしたことになるんですよ
あああああ
除霊しなきゃこれであるまあでは戦後でも回ると思うんだよ
ません集中力が散漫だぞ
ポロポロボイニャー
ano 違ってだ
me
rar
うっはっはー tano
ブーブんだろうニュース aaa
ええええええ
rar
ストーカーの被害に遭いましたもつもつへ
東京に
引っ越しまもばんえ茶房
car
ni
生後中です
4年フレーズを上げときますか
にゃっはー
田んぼすってーっ
人だって大きい
スポンともうっっ
me
ran
なあ8キロではてってますねやんば俺
まあレベコのグッズを好きで僕って言葉なぁ競馬モーゼ
足しってますか
まあ休まず版ですね500です
以前だったような美味しいんだよ欲しいのは本当にあのなんか別に動く城は抜けます
ジョング諸島問題だ
ああふわぁ
[音楽]
入って保護者負けたくねーな
ee
ni
はい時で今年はずっとことはいろいろあったんですけどまぁ良い一年だったのではない
でしょうか
ってか役の子だったんですよね来年はもっと良い年になることです間違いないと思うし
来年の目標はですね
あそれは来年を何でも用としてたまたですこちらがいろいろあったんですけどそれを
しっかり踏まえた上でねさらに身ができるように頑張っていこうと思いますそれでは皆
さん2017年も本当にありがとうございました
良い音所じゃあ
さて彼の日のメーカー
[音楽]